hey y'all it's the first movie
retrospective of 2020 mm-hmm that sounds
like it doesn't even sound like yeah
we're in the twenties now in the Roaring
Twenties their first retrospective we're
gonna do in the roaring 20s is across
whole movie Jenny gave me a Christmas
present of Big Trouble in Little China
look at the box isn't that cool of [ __ ]
yeah and this is like the deluxe blu-ray
edition that came from with a chef a
factory a factory it's like my other
ones but for some reason it came like an
extra special really large awesome box
yes it's it's steelbook yeah it's Fanta
it's two discs two discs and so much
actually on this we have not even been
able to watch all of it together so much
of it we watched quite a bit of it
though I had seen Big Trouble in Little
China when it came out I watched it on
VHS I didn't get to see it in theatres
yeah and I remember enjoying it but I
also remember thinking it was kind of
like a cheesy Raiders of the Lost Ark
knockoff I liked it but then I kind of
quickly forgot about it but having seen
it again in the format you're supposed
to see it in you know with the right
aspect ratio and all the nice colors all
the nice colors it was good it was a
cool flick real cool flick and I
understand it a lot better now than I
did when I was a kid like it when it
came out I feel like and this happens
poor John Carpenter this happens a lot
of John Carpenter movies is that the
movie comes out I mean Big Trouble in
Little China came out in 1986 and it was
notoriously a very large bomb I believe
it was pulled from theaters I think we
were watching some interview we watched
an old interview with John Carpenter and
one with Kurt Russell and some of the
other people who worked on the movie and
I think that they pulled pulled it out
of the theaters after three or four days
just because it wasn't doing so well
because I think it only costs it cost
between 20 and 25 million dollars to
make and it only made 11 million back
yeah I can understand it why it bombed
though I mean I can too it was in that
time period it was very head of its time
a lot of junk artists work you can takes
like several decades for them to get
appreciated what this was given used
they
bring in Hong Kong theatre to the United
States in an American movie yeah it's
very much like a kung-fu flick oh yeah
before conflict kind of food flicks were
cool yeah I mean there was like a lot of
people watched him like uh 42nd Street
and stuff like that you know what I mean
a lot of people were into those but it
wasn't this was like I this might be one
of the first mainstream movies that
actually attempted to do like a Hong
Kong theatre type of movie yeah in that
type of format you know what I mean yeah
I would say that this is kind of like
basically Mortal Kombat or Teenage
Mutant Mutant Ninja Turtles it's like
that's a tone yeah well and that's where
I mean Mortal Kombat swiped a couple
characteristics and I mean they didn't
rip it off there were omage in it
because they did like say that that's
where they got the character from and
everything like that but they did kind
of have a ninja craze for a while you
know but like I said that wasn't enough
for a full big-budget movie this was
actually a kind of a big-budget movie
yeah like I said and it's weird because
I didn't realize this at the time I
didn't see this in the theater I
actually ended up seeing this on cable a
couple of times interestingly and we'll
kind of get into this a little bit in a
minute there was like some kind of
rivalry between this movie and the
golden child because they came out the
same year now I will say that at the
time
I liked the golden child better like I
saw it a bunch more times but having
seen both of the movies recently I like
this one better I think I've lice till
like the golden child but I now think
this one is like a much better movie
it's a bigger movie it definitely is
more ambitious movie for sure um you
know in the sense that a lot more
special effect I can get why like I said
this is a movie that I don't think it
would be hard to sell nowadays and I
will tell you that you know Dwayne
Johnson his production company yeah they
are doing I hear that they're doing a
sequel to this initially they were
talking about doing a remake and that
like you know the rock was gonna play
the Kurt Russell character but everyone
was like what the [ __ ] nobody can be
Jack Burton except for Kurt Russell yeah
and he's like no no he's like it's gonna
be a continuation of the story it's a
sequel you know he's like I'm not gonna
replace Kurt Russell obviously because
that's that character but they're gonna
just like set in the same universe I
guess
but I think what the initial conception
of this movie and this movie had a
really really troubled production
history which I didn't realize until I
was watching like all the extras all the
extras and [ __ ] about it
apparently the two guys who write at
first
Gary Goldman and David Weinstein this
was their first screenplay now their
initial conception they wanted to do
something and apparently this is a whole
this is a whole sub-genre called weird
West or weird western where they wanted
to set in the 1880s in San Francisco and
it was gonna combine like a classic
Western with some comedy but also
Chinese mysticism because they thought
those ideas would like kind of be really
cool together so originally the Jack
Burton character was conceived as a
cowboy who rides into town and has and
encounters like all that like the the
story about lo pan I think is pretty
much the only thing that is the same
from the original script like the guy
that had the curse and he was like he
doesn't have a body I guess he's not a
ghost exactly but he's kind of like he's
a ghost yeah he's a Chinese good he was
cursed to be like incorporeal or
whatever where it's like he doesn't have
a body so he wants a body like he can
have a body sometimes but it's like a
crappy old one that's like this huh like
[ __ ] up and he's like in a wheelchair
and stuff but it's like so his whole
quest throughout the movie is that he
has to marry and sacrifice a green-eyed
woman yeah and then the demon whose name
is what's the demons name I can't even
remember forgot Chang died or something
like that the demon will give him a body
like give him his body back and
apparently he's gonna be immortal or
something like that so this is a
complicated story
the Chinese ghost is kind of like a
vampire to look yet I mean to
immortality and and also like a sorcerer
yeah cuz he can do a bunch of sorcery
it's pretty cool flick it's um it was
ahead of its time it I can understand
why I failed them
I can't as well it's not the movie that
the studio wanted yes do do wanted
basically basically they wanted Raiders
of the Lost Ark yeah and what they got
instead was a kung-fu
version of ghostbusters pretty much it's
pretty and it's it's it's got the tone
is like ghostbusters
so it is kind of yeah like the first
Ghostbusters it's like Ghostbusters
MORTAL KOMBAT Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and a comfo flick yeah like oh
man and Indiana Jones and it's funny and
yeah and it's funny and Curt across the
crustle crustle does a good job you know
in escape from New York you know when he
did Snake Plissken he was channeling um
or what's his name a Clint Eastwood yeah
you could tell it's Clint Eastwood I see
this one and he's supposed to be a
cowboy they wanted him to be a captain
he's channeling John Wayne and that's
going and doing over-the-top John Wayne
he's just Americanist [ __ ] I mean hyper
Americanisms and the Carpenters say okay
he's it was gonna be kind of situation
like in you know Raiders of the Lost Ark
never his Lost Ark but Temple of Doom
where you had Indy and he hit a little
Chinese sidekick named you know short
round or kind of like you know the Green
Hornet and Kato gonna be something kind
of like that but it was it's kind of odd
carpenter didn't really want to do that
because the entire cast is Chinese
pretty much there's only a few like non
Asian actors in this yeah and it's kind
of this white Savior [ __ ] element we
want to turn that on its head what I was
doing where white guy shows up and kills
all the monsters and all the ghosts for
the Chinese people to come they're like
oh thank you white man yeah it would it
would have been funny it would've been
artist [ __ ] for that so if they have to
get that [ __ ] done but it's got a it's
got to be entertaining it can't look
that corny you know which I guess Temple
of Doom pulled it off eh you know cuz
you know a good indie shows up
single-handedly saves all the Indians
from a [ __ ] from the OD thug easy
easy but yeah that's the movie by hero
you know it's a hero tale you know
that's what the studio wanted
carpenter kind of flipped it on its head
where you got this John Wayne type
character and then the little Chinese
guy but the little Chinese guy's the one
that's really doing all that actually
the hero he's actually won all the heavy
liftin scarab at Jack Burton yeah thinks
he's the hare shepherd trying to be the
first time he's doing and he doesn't
know anything I mean he basically he
only gets involved in this entire
situation with the sex traffickers and
the demon guy and everything like that
he only gets involved because him and
Wang we're playing a game and like you
know Wang lost a bet and so he's like
well I'm gonna come with you to like
make sure you give me my money
hahaha and then Wang's like oh I got to
go to the airport and pick up my
girlfriend you know or maybe my fiancee
and so while they're at the airport like
you know a girl gets kidnapped by sex
slaves and like Jack Burton intervenes
and stuff like that so jack is coming
into this big like milieu of like
Chinese mythology and like two warring
gangs and like a demon guy and
everything he has no [ __ ] clue how
the hell is going guys a [ __ ] truck
stripe in the porkchop Express and he
just like brings pigs into Chinatown
like TV you know slaughtered yes he's
kind of the King the comedic relief he's
yeah I'm the sidekick really but he D is
heroic he does pull it off yeah but you
know but by just being an [ __ ] and
not give it up and yeah he is brave but
he's just this is the first time he's
doing any of this [ __ ] he's trying to
play it off he's basically and both John
Carpenter and Kurt Russell said this
they thought they were very amused like
coming up with stuff that this character
could do because they're like he thinks
he's the here but he's really like he's
a blowhard and he's also like a little
bit of an idiot yeah um but he has like
heroic he is brave and he does like step
in and help his friends he's not like
trying to get out of it or anything but
he doesn't he's never really shot a gun
before he's never really fought before
so he's like all this stuff where
they're trying to like there's [ __ ]
great scene at the end like during the
you know one of the big main comfo
fights and Kurt Russell was like man
it's like I can't really do like all
that you know fighting and stuff like
that he's like how about if I get
knocked out like two seconds into the
fight that he's just unconscious
he wakes up he finishes it yes so that
was like his idea is like
so you just like shoots into the ceiling
I'm les ceiling and like the cement
falls on his head and it knocks him out
like that you know the thing of the
fight so I like that they were kind of
like trying to subvert this trope where
because Kurt Russell was like when he
and niche initially um he I don't think
he was actually the first choice for the
role because John Carpenter was um you
know not really the first choice like I
said the two guys that wrote the
original original script someone bought
the script but then they said we want to
really like it they tried to redo it and
they're like it's not work and I don't
want it to be a period piece I don't
want it to be set in the 1880s because
that's like affecting everything so you
know this other writer who was like a
script doctor I can't remember his name
but he was the same guy that directed
Adventures of Buckaroo Banzai
and he basically retold the entire
script and set it in modern Chinatown
like I said the only thing he kept was
like the lo pan vac story about his
curse and the demon and everything and
that was like all that they kept and
turned he turned Jack Burton into a
truck driver but you know there was like
a thing with like the writers guild and
it's like the original writers were mad
they're like well we want writing credit
even though everything had been changed
because they have rules where you know
you can't you can't like have somebody
write it and then take the whole thing
and rewrite the whole concept and then
go well you guys don't get any credit
you can't really do that so I so I think
the original two guys got writing credit
but then the script doctor guy got like
attributed credit and [ __ ] like that
now John Carpenter um interestingly he
had actually been offered to direct the
golden child but he turned it down
however he's like the weird thing is
that we're working on this script and
then the golden child was also kind of
floating around and they were working on
that script and he's like what are the
odds of like two action movies there I
mean they're not exactly the same but
they're two like action movies with like
a Western person like going into like
worth of Elvis Asian mysticism and they
don't really know what's going on and
they're kind of like wisecracking and
stuff so he's like it was similar enough
that they had to push the production of
Big Trouble in Little China like way up
because they said we want this out
before the golden child so it doesn't
look like we've ripped it off so they
said that it actually ended up coming
out five months before that but like I
said the the weird thing the special
effects on this I have
it's the same guy it's Richard Edlund I
think it's real good he added boss film
studios or whatever his thing he used to
work for Industrial Light magic and then
he went started his own business he did
the first ghostbusters and so you can
tell it's the same effects like ghost
folks I mean the effects in this when we
were watching it on blu-ray we said they
look like they've been cleaned up and I
don't think that they have well I saw it
on VHS and yeaji VHS it looks like [ __ ]
yeah okay just the way it was the old
TVs that we had and everything yeah and
I never saw it they're supposed to look
like in the theater but you see this
thing on blu-ray man a good TV effects
look really good it looks really good
it's really good especially like all the
light work like all the Lightning the
one scene where egg Shen you know the
magician who's played by James Hong
who's [ __ ] great he was also in he's
been a bunch of Chinese masters in it
it's got everything yeah there's like a
monster that looks kind of like [ __ ]
Bigfoot there's like this floating head
with like all these eyeballs that it
like a beholder from them yeah it like
floats around and stuff and they made
that all like with yeah the tearing it
has a weird looking weird looking sewer
monster that pops out for a second some
of this [ __ ] you only see it for a few
seconds yeah that's kind of a shame
because especially that one sewer
monster it's like they we were watching
some of the extras and they were talking
about although I mean you would see like
all the work they would be like
sculpting this really cool like a
monster and you saw it for literally a
second and a half the movie I think
would have made a lot of money and it
would have been remembered if it didn't
have two main things going against it
one when Carpenter screened the movie
for the studio execs they were [ __ ]
furious
it wasn't the movie that they wanted
they didn't really get the humor they
didn't get that it was supposed to be
funny they wanted they wanted Temple of
Doom yeah they wanted okay and this
whole humor aspect and they just didn't
like it and evidently now they talked
about it in the extras no names were
mentioned the person who said but but
carpenter and a studio executive got a
big [ __ ] fight right there in the
theater and that studio exact [ __ ]
it's not a suck this movie and he sunk
it by not not put enough money into
towards promotion yeah and they gave it
a kind of a [ __ ] up poster that
yeah Russell was talking about that he's
like here's the thing like on purpose to
be kind of [ __ ] up now now here's
we've got to go back to the second
here's another thing the reason why a
[ __ ] up this movie somebody thought it
was a good idea to go to San Francisco
and approach the Chinese community and
let him know about this movie and that
you know tries to say that it wasn't
racist and they did that in public and
that's that's not gonna work because all
you still take is one person to say it's
racist and that's what who's gonna and
it was essentially one person that's
like had a big campaign anyone else
really cared about nobody gave a [ __ ]
and and the reason why nobody gives a
[ __ ] is they don't know anything about
the Chinese in China it's illegal to
show anything about mysticism and ghosts
the the Chinese supposed like the CCP
tries to [ __ ] can stamp out all
mysticism from [ __ ] movies the
Chinese that are here in San Francisco
don't give a [ __ ] about that
there's no reason there was no reason to
even talk to them because the only thing
that resulted was negative press and
they said nothing they would they would
it wouldn't have dude we should like I
should just release that [ __ ] just
write about it is that you would think
of all the movies to complain about this
one would seem like really low on the
list because almost all Chinese all
almost all Asian casts um the Asians
were the heroes the white guy was pretty
much kind of made a clown it kinda yeah
he was a hero it to but he was yeah he
was kind of like bumbling and kind of an
idiot and he was obviously like the
sidekick type of character yeah so he
didn't know it and he was the sidekick
and that's like it and Kurt Russell said
specifically that that's how he wanted
to play him is like as someone who
thinks he's the hero when he's actually
the sidekick yeah and like I said I
think what ended up happening - I mean
there was a lot of reasons why I think
this movie wasn't and this happens like
I said with a lot of John Carpenter
movies like of whatever genre it's
always kind of like they come out like
everyone's just kind of like men or like
people don't go see her they don't get
it but then like you know 10 20 years
later it finds its audience and it's
like has a huge cult following and
that's exactly what happened with this
one I think one the premise was pretty
weird
although the golden child premise was
yeah we're doing
not by today's standards we had by 1986
standards because the you know there was
not only the combination of like kind of
an action-movie with Chinese mysticism
which hadn't really been done if either
at all or hadn't been done all that much
there was also the strange humor you
know the kind of inversion of the hero's
sidekick characters the whole thing
between and particularly between Kurt
Russell's character and Kim Cattrall's
character where John Carpenter I think
it told them Howard Hawks the [ __ ] out
of it cuz they're like just real fast
talking like it was like from the 30s
and I think a lot of people didn't
really get that either you know what I
mean and also what happened to was that
1986 was the same year that aliens came
out and it actually came out only a
couple weeks after this and there was a
huge huge media blitz and this was the
same studio that was putting aliens out
so I think what ended up happening
weirdly before this movie came out like
the test screenings that they did were
really really positive like every like
all the public members of the public
that's not we're like really into it so
I think at first they were thinking it
was gonna be like a big blockbuster and
Kurt Russell like in the interview on
the thing he was like he was saying that
even when he was doing the rounds of
like talk shows and stuff people were
like oh how does it feel to be in a
movie that's gonna come out it's gonna
be this big blockbuster he's like but
then like as the release date got closer
and closer he's like I didn't see any TV
spots for it I didn't really see he's
like in the poster like the painting on
the poster is nice but one it doesn't
really look like Kurt Russell to he's
like you know yeah it's cool that they
put me really big like on the poster
everything but I wasn't like a humongous
star at that time so it's not like I was
like the main selling point they
probably should have like you know
played up another aspect of it maybe
made up the villains in the monsters
yeah or something like it should have
been more like that so you would kind of
know what kind of movie it was and the
poster should have been dark it
shouldn't have been a light-hearted kind
of like yeah even though it is kind of a
wacky you should have been more like a
ghostbusters poster that's kind of what
I think that they should have done so
you know I'm not saying they did that
perp I am saying that probably after the
studio saw the final cut and everything
that there probably yeah we don't really
get it it's like aliens is coming out
soon maybe we should just take the
budget quietly that we were gonna spend
they were only gonna spend two or three
million dollars on marketing for this
movie and John Carpenter was like I
don't even know what the [ __ ] they did
with that because I didn't hardly see
any marketing for this before it came
out and I think they quietly just said
hey let's move that over De Anza give
that an extra three months and I'm not
[ __ ] on aliens obviously because
that's a [ __ ] masterpiece but you
know so I think it suffered too from
being in the same studio as aliens and
that being like the big thing that they
were thinking was getting big money that
year so it basically ended up being
something that was almost kind of like
something directed DVD oh and this movie
didn't really look all that great on
direct to DVD [ __ ] baby didn't exist
at the VHS yeah so people saw it at
Blockbuster and it really didn't look
that good on the movies of the on the TV
screens of the day CRT televisions just
yeah didn't have the definition they
were fuzzy and by today's standards so
the movie just didn't have the height
behind it yeah aliens had and
Ghostbusters had and it just was
forgotten yeah and it was like that's
kind of it's unjust you know it was a
good movie yeah and like I said over the
years day like many of John Carpenter's
movies it definitely like got a
humongous cult following so much so that
it got a video game it got a board game
it got a card game it has nowadays just
from a couple years ago it has a whole
like comic book series one of which is a
crossover with Jack Burton and Snake
Plissken which I actually went to see if
they had any left and they're all sold
out
this as far as I could tell but they're
they also did like a series that's
called old man Jack like his continuing
things and everything and I think we
mentioned it earlier but the the one
character that's in there you know
there's those three characters called
the three storms like rain and thunder
and lightning or whatever
yeah that's where Raiden from Mortal
Kombat like with the big straw hat and
the lightning coming out of his hands
and also yeah and I think there's a
villain too in Mortal Kombat that was
taken from the villain in this movie as
well like when he's in his incarnation
with all his like really uh
the multi hand guy yeah yeah so it says
so like the makers of Mortal Kombat like
and have come out as saying that they
were amahzing big trouble a little china
into with these characters and Mortal
Kombat and stuff like that so I was
watching this one I think they're called
off-the-shelf reviews it's like these
two British guys that just sit on a
couch and talk about movies for 40
minutes kind of like we do and they and
the one of them had a shirt and he just
loves this movie this is like this is
like one of his favorite John Carpenter
movies and he had a shirt that had Kurt
Russell on it with the with the gun like
pointed out but it said it's all in the
reflexes yeah like I was like oh that's
it dude I gotta want it alright yeah he
mentioned the gun I'm gonna talk about
the gun yeah let's talk about the gun is
the god is an inter tech 9 which total
which was that was a [ __ ] popular
cheeseball assault pistols what they
called him back in the day back in the
late 80s it was originally supposed to
be an open bolt fully automatic
submachine gun that they were gonna sell
to the law enforcement in Europe but
they never really could get a buyer so
they kind of dumbed it down a little bit
made it bolt forward happen you know
with hammer and made it a semi-auto
pistol here the United States you can
get them for cheap back in those days
like 200 bucks yeah and they weren't
really all that known for reliability
they had problems you know they jammed
every now and then things broke on them
but that actually perfectly made it up
with that Jack character it did yeah
there's something trying to be something
that it isn't but it yeah on it it's
kind of work and that's why you know
they gave him that pistol and that
pistol did not have a stellar reputation
yeah well maybe that's why maybe whoever
like decided to put that particular crop
in there well yeah like what something's
real showy but it's not that great
shitty that somebody did that on purpose
that was mine yeah yeah give a
technology is a really enables faces if
a pistol could have a mullet it would be
a tech man with a big knife you could
have like a little yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
that's what it'd be another thing oh I
have to mention
because ever since we watch this we
watch this movie a couple nights ago
and ever since then the [ __ ] theme
song has been stuck in my head it will
not be dislodged and I have movie it is
like the theme song could you just call
Big Trouble in Little China was actually
performed by John Carpenter's Band the
Coupe de Ville and I believe that that
is John Carpenter singing there was a
really really cheesy music video made
for this it's delightful I'm pretty sure
it's on goes yeah and it's like I'm
pretty sure it's John Carpenter singing
in the in the video even though it I
wouldn't have guessed that that was what
his singing voice sounded like but the
other two guys in the band I didn't
realize this the other two guys in the
Coupe de villes are nick castle who was
the guy that played Michael Myers and he
also co-wrote Escape from New York and
then the third guy is Tommy Lee Wallace
the same guy that directed Halloween 3
season of the witch Fright Night - and
the it miniseries from 1990 so that was
like his all-star band but they did like
a lot of songs for this and she's like I
just thought just the regular score what
was real it is yeah you know it's
carpenter what you can tell when
carpenters you know scoring his own
movies well yeah he has a very
distinctive style and he said that was
good he said that specifically he's like
when I was doing the score for this he's
like so many movies like that had
Chinese actors or had like kind of a
Chinese setting or a Chinatown setting
he's like he's like they always use what
he called quote unquote rinky-dink chop
suey immediately and he's like I really
didn't want to do that now so he just
went with his like regular kind of score
and it actually does serve the movie
very well yeah it's good I will say that
it's like this movie you really kind of
because it's edited really quickly and
it's like kind of like I said the story
like the backstory of the demon and
everything is kind of complicated so you
really have to listen to like whatever
like everyone's conversations or you
will just have no idea what's going on
you'll just like there's people running
around there's like guys with like like
shooting lightning out of their hands
and what's great about this movie is
that because of the Edit because of how
how cool it looks and just everything
that happens at each see it's
action-packed pretty much yeah and the
acting the overt over-the-top acting
yeah it is very over-the-top don't
really have to pay attention of the
movie there you don't it's just like
your son right and [ __ ] yeah this you
can just drink and watch the movie just
laugh you're basically like they're just
fighting yeah magic guy it's a very -
save the girls because the tone is not
serious it's very kind of bonkers and
over-the-top and it's just a fun movie
yeah so it's not something you sit there
and go oh what does he mean by I said if
you want to know like what the backstory
is it is kind of like a comedy you just
have to like listen what they're saying
yeah I was gonna MIT I forgot to mention
to that like you know the prologue of
the movie like with egg Shen talking to
that lawyer about what a hero Jack
Burton was and stuff like that yeah yeah
that was tacked on yeah because I mean
initially the movie was just supposed to
start with Jack Burton coming down the
highway in his truck you know like on
the CB or whatever but the studio made
him put that in there because they're
like well we can't have a movie we're
like the white guy is not a hero
you know where the Chinese guy is the
hero right so like so so he had to come
up with like some scene to tack on the
beginning to like make the studio happen
a deal weren't happy I think what I
think what the deal was is I think
executives thought that whether or not
Jack was the hero or not is in question
in this movie and yet he's got to
definitely be the hero he wrote draw the
movie yeah they knew the demographics
yeah I mean they were trying to make
money so they tack those things on the
front but they're talking about how
brave he was you know yeah in retrospect
you know which adds to the movies the SP
it's kind of funny but it's in here like
when you know they know the story behind
why that was just because it seems a
little trihard what was it the movie
that they wanted yeah and it's just
funny there's not the movie the studio
one it's funny that you get egg Shen at
the beginning like in the context of the
movie like talking about how awesome
Jack Burton is even though Wang Chi was
the one that did it yeah but then adding
that in the very beginning because the
studio wanted made it even more
ridiculous yeah so it may be it like
worked out because his character was
supposed to be like I said he is a
heroic character he's brave he does
rescue people and he does help out his
friends like I said he doesn't really
he's reluctant at first cuz he just
wants his truck back cuz his truck gets
stolen but he he does actually want to
help his friend cuz Wang Chi is his
friend he's a hero so he is her mother
oh yeah but it's kind of like he's he's
kind of stumbled into some you said he
doesn't understand yeah but he said but
he's yeah he's in over his head but he's
like just really cocky and he she's like
yeah I'm gonna sort this [ __ ] out I'm
Way you know I mean American is [ __ ]
that's okay that's what a good American
man's gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] his way
through it and like John Wayne would
shoots and kills that guy was what did
you killed that guy's that's your first
guy you ever killed news [ __ ] no hell no
[Laughter]
he's got like such great like comedic
timing in this you know just some of
this [ __ ] like one day he busts open
that one door and there's all those bad
guys back there and he just closes it
real quick and it's like I think we
might be trapped it's just like all that
really funny [ __ ] it's just a good just
a good movies just fun it looks great
it's held up if you can find it watch it
yeah I mean John Carbonite man that this
right here yeah this is really really
nice
yeah and I'm sure I think that came out
in 2013 2014 something like that but
yeah it's a shell factory slash screen
factory it's a fairly reasonably priced
it was a little bit expensive but not
really for them they're probably the
other ones didn't come in that big case
yeah ones that I bought that didn't come
in that big case we're probably around
$30 that one was I think 50 or so yeah
that's pretty high this was a different
this is pride top-notch and it's like
now I'm wonderin if all the other John
Carpenter movies if they have a version
that has like that big-ass box
maybe because that big nest box is
pretty bad I never sent me a big-ass box
before I know I've never seen that's why
I was shocked that I was like well of
all movies of all John Carpenter's
movies to have that like you make sure
my little China seemed like an odd one
yeah you think it would be like this
you would think or Halloween yeah maybe
there is a version with like that now
I'm gonna have to look it up but yeah so
I got him that for Christmas so we
decided to review the movie because I
feel like this is one like I said it's
it's gotten a lot of appreciation now
but you know at the time it was kind of
[ __ ] on got 10 years ahead of its time
it was way ahead of his time and it's
like you know if you want to see a John
Carpenter kung-fu movie you know
this is your opportunity if you ever
once yeah so definitely um check it out